ce soir je ne vous lira qu'une seule
lettre qui vient monsieur georges
perrier à bagnes bien sûr cette aide
concerne shadoks monsieur père y est
content et il dit outre l'idiotie du
sujet les dessins sont vraiment au
dessous de tout la technique qui est
vraiment ramené à sa plus simple
expression
j'espère pour vous que seul le manque de
crédits en est la cause
aujourd'hui nous avons installé nos
caméras au service de la recherche avec
le service de la recherche produit les
shadoks
beaucoup de gens se disent mais qu'est
ce que c'est que cette recherche est ce
que vraiment ils sont pauvres ou est-ce
qu'il gaspille l'argent du
téléspectateur savez que vous en voyez
toujours d'ailleurs je vous signale que
s'arrête doublé avant la fin de l'année
dix mille francs par an pour regarder la
télévision
donc par conséquent nous avons installé
une caméra accès au service de la
recherche et monsieur m'a lambert
vautour a bien voulu nous accueillir en
approchez vous n'ayez pas peur
vous êtes le chef des dessinateurs du
service de la sphère des mous qui
produisent et de son dock recherche de
rire
excuse moi avant avant de commencer
l'interview vous auriez pas une petite
cigarette au cdh est bonne celle-là on
compte pour merci au film possible le
service de la recherche c'est ça c'est
triste c'est ici voilà c'est tout ça on
a l'impression qu'on va rentrer dans les
bureaux un peu un peu froid très moderne
et puis quand même le travail est là
quand on entend des conditions qui sont
quand même des collections de plein air
c'est extraordinaire oué enfin écoutés
honnêtement je vais vous dire
franchement nous nous manquons de coûts
nous manquons de locaux et nous sommes
nous sommes très très défavorisé
vis-à-vis de l'administration par
exemple des locaux d'aidés publiques
extra haute attention le marché ne
marchez pas sur les sur les dessins sur
la nécessaire attention
alors qu'est ce que c'est ça alors ça
c'est un essai c'est un essai graphique
alors je vais faire quoi alors là on
essaie de faire c'est pour par exemple
de ces pour la l'émission qui passera
bientôt c'est pour le procès john
d'impôts alors là on essaye de
moderniser le buffet
alors ça ce sont les essais couleur oui
c'est ça ce sont les essais couleurs
tous avrillé oui tout ça ce sont des cc
couler
ça qu'est ce que c'est alors ça c'est la
voiture du producteur je vais vous dire
une chose
on est les uns sur les autres on est les
uns sur les autres je ne sais pas si
vous vous rendez compte pour nous autres
artistes bousbaa eh bien on a le
créateur oui c'est ça on a besoin on a
besoin de se concentrer on a besoin
d'être s'isoler un petit peu de de
rentrer en soi même alors là je voudrais
lancer un appel
si vous avez des crayons plus la caméra
et ça a marché avec le château
d'hautefort on a trouvé des tas de
crédit alors en phase là comme ça a
lancé un appel aux gens comme des
crayons du papier